Lasagne rolls ganz einfach und schnell
selbst gemacht wir Braten das
Hackfleisch mit Zwiebeln und Knoblauch
angeben Gemüse nach Wahl dazu und würzen
das ganze mit Sahne ablöschen
Tomatenmark dazugeben und fertig ist
unsere Füllung die fertigen
Lasagneblätter bekommt ihr im Kühlregal
die Füllung reingeben Käse darf nicht
fehlen und das ganze einrollen die
genauen Mengenangaben schreibe ich euch
natürlich wie immer auf ihr verrührt für
die Tomatensoße einfach nur ein paar
Zutaten gibt es oben drüber und dann
über backt ihr die Lasagne rolls mit
ganz viel Käse es schmeckt so unfassbar
gut macht's unbedingt nach